in other videos we've done linear
regressions by hand but we mentioned
that most regressions are actually done
using some type of computer or
calculator and so what we're going to do
in this video is look at an example of
the output that we might see from a
computer and to not be intimidated by it
and to see how it gives us the equation
for the regression line and some of the
other data it gives us
so here it tells us cheryl dixon is
interested to see if students who
consume more caffeine tend to study more
as well
she randomly selects 20 students at her
school and records their caffeine intake
in milligrams and the number of hours
spent studying a scatter plot of the
data showed a linear relationship
this is a computer output from a least
squares regression analysis on the data
so we have these things called the
predictors coefficient and then we have
these other things standard error of
coefficient t and p and then all of
these things down here how do we make
sense of this in order to come up with
an equation for our linear regression
so let's just get straight on our
variables
let's just say that we say that y
is the thing that we're trying to
predict so this is the hours spent
studying
hours
and then let's say x is what we think
explains the hour study here's one of
the things that explains the hour
studying and this is the amount of
caffeine ingested
so this is
caffeine
consumed
in milligrams
and so our regression line would have
the form y hat this tells us this is a
linear regression is trying to estimate
the actual y values for given x's is
going to be equal to
m x
plus b
now how do we figure out what m and b
are based on this computer output so
when you look at this table here this
first column says predictor and it says
constant and it has caffeine
and so all this is saying is when you're
trying to predict the number of hours
studying when you're trying to predict
why there's essentially two inputs there
there is the constant value and there is
your variable in this case caffeine that
you're using to predict the amount that
you study and so this tells you the
coefficients on each the coefficient on
a constant is the constant you could
view this as the coefficient on the x to
the zeroth term and so the coefficient
on the constant that is the constant
2.544
and then the coefficient on
the caffeine
well we just said that x is the caffeine
consumed so this is that coefficient
0.164
[Music]
so just like that we actually have the
equation for the regression line that is
why these computer things are useful so
we can just write it out
y hat is equal to
0.165
x plus
2.544 2.544
so that's the regression line what is
this other information they give us
well i won't give you a very satisfying
answer because all of this is actually
useful for inferential statistics to
think about things like well what is the
probability that this is chance that we
got something to fit this well so this
right over here is the r squared and if
you wanted to figure out the r from this
you would just take the square root here
we could say that r is going to be equal
to the square root of
0.60032 depending on how much precision
you have but you might say well how do
we know if r is a positive square root
or the negative square root of that r
can take on values between negative one
and positive one
and the answer is you would look at the
slope here we have a positive slope
which tells us that r is going to be
positive if we had a negative slope then
r would then we would take the negative
square root now this right here is the
adjusted r squared and we really don't
have to worry about it too much when
we're thinking about just bivariate data
we're talking about caffeine and our
studying in this case if we started to
have more variables that tried to
explain the our studying
then we would care about adjusted r
squared but we're not going to do that
just yet last but not least this s
variable this is the standard deviation
of the residuals which we study in other
videos and why is that useful well
that's a measure of how well the
regression line fits the data
it's a measure of we could say the
typical error
so big takeaway computers are useful
they'll give you a lot of data and the
key thing is how do you pick out the
things that you actually need because if
you know how to do it it can be quite
straightforward